you
welcome welcome to cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we are
hosting webinars every Tuesday
my name is Nasir Mohammed and I'm Chris
page customer Solutions Architect with
Apogee part of Google cloud and today we
will be talking about securing your
api's with Apogee
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have Google's on standby
to answer them so with that let's get
started
these are our names these are our
pictures and here's the agenda so today
we will go over a brief overview of
Apogee and then do a deep dive of Apogee
at security what we'll follow that up
with a demo I cooled them with a Chris
gonna show and then we will open it up
for question and answers so what is
Apogee Apogee is a comprehensive API
platform it provides three core modules
API management module that is
responsible for providing development
and management of API proxies developers
services as well as a module that is
responsible for providing a fully
managed and highly engaging developer
portal and then the analytics module the
analytics module will give you
visibility in the usage of your API so
thereby providing you the visibility for
the effectiveness for you to analyze the
effectiveness of your API program a page
is also the industry leader for three
consecutive years being on the top right
of the Magic Quadrant and this is the
philosophy of apogee thinking outside in
this philosophy at Apogee challenges
traditional approaches of API management
traditionally the thing about API
management in terms of exposure right
you have services which you want to
expose so you come up with API and you
publish an API catalog and you think the
job is done well not really if you think
about it from an end user perspective
and work backwards from there that leads
to better results and also to
realizing the importance of each actor
on this chain and providing them with
enhanced experiences while they interact
with your API platform becomes the key
for a successful API program and using
this platform and using this design
pattern we have shown success to many of
our clients now having said that let's
change the role I let's change the lens
of this pattern and let's look at this
pattern in terms of security you know
you see we cover a lot of ground here we
and which opens up a room for a lot of
security controls to be in place so each
actor on this chain are presents a
unique set of security requirements and
we will go through these requirements
and I want you guys while I'm walking
through this flow here I want you to
relate to your use cases your API use
cases which you are working on and see
how you're addressing the security
concerns which I'm gonna walk through
here so let's start this exercise from
left to right on the left while we
publish our API so on the Internet how
do we protect this API from hackers
when I say hikers in back of your mind
you should be thinking about sequel
injection threatening content protection
denial of service etc right so how can
we protect our API from hackers who are
trying to bring our systems down and how
can we protect from data scrapers the
data scrapers who are trying to steal
over data for their competitive
advantage right leading to the next
security concern which is how do you
authenticate and how do you know if the
incoming users are legitimate uses and
if he or she really have the needed
permissions to access this api's
likewise applications an enterprise can
have many applications how can you
identify these applications how can you
make sure the api's that are invoked
from these applications are our related
api's are our api that are allowed for
this application to invoke now more
importantly as
talking or we are looking from a
security and governance perspective how
do you ensure that a decommissioned app
can no longer access this api's moving
further towards the right comes in
developer the app developers create
great apps now how can we help them
onboard on the API platform how can we
register this app developers on the API
platform providing them the the
appropriate set of controls or
appropriate set of API switch they can
access without much friction and that
becomes a key moving for the right to
the in the chain comes the api's and the
api teams now this poses are very
interesting and a critical security
concern which is how do you ensure that
the API developers know what they are
developing with respect to security
right are the opening up any wonder
abilities while they're developing this
API are they adhering to enterprise
standards while they are developing this
API that becomes a critical concern and
then finally on the backend how do you
authenticate to back end how do you pass
in to the backend the information of the
original requester that invoked this API
and how do we address data security on
wire or in transit and at rest so these
are the concerns right that comes up and
the list is long now let's see how
Apogee provides our addresses are some
of the security concerns let's start
from left to right again Apogee provides
our Apogee provides our in a
behavior-based threat protection module
to protect our API from hackers and data
scrapers Apogee also protects our api's
from threatening content protection by
providing threatening content protection
policies attacks like sequel injection
attacks like a cross-site scripting
attacks XML bombs or XML reference
attacks Apogee can have a signature
based threat protection policy deployed
to take care of these attacks
apart from this as you publish your API
is on internet your ap eyes are prone to
spikes in traffic
Appaji effectively protects against
spikes of traffic thereby helping
preventing our back-end systems going
down at PG identifies applications using
API keys and authenticate end users
using OAuth the industry-standard
authentication protocol appetit provides
all five grand types of Earth Apogee
also can act as an fully compliant
authorization server and an OAuth
resource server after addressing the
identification and authentication
problems you know the next challenge
would be the authorization challenge
which becomes a very complex challenge
to address write or to solve Apogee
addresses this in two factions Apogee
divides the authorization space into two
coarse-grain authorizations and
fine-grain authorization for
coarse-grain authorization Apogee
introduces this concept called API
products API products help you slice and
dice your API that makes business sense
now this API products in turn will also
act as your authorization enforces
similarly you can have CUDA enforcement
on the products right now when it comes
to fine-grain authorizations Apogee
provides you tools and policies to
implement scope based access control
policies and claims based access control
policies leveraging Roth scopes and JWT
tokens appetit provides logging
capabilities for auditability there by
covering identification authentication
authorization and auditability aspects
of security
Appaji provides for developers developer
portal and also management api's for
them to have a single sign-on and self
registration features for them to log
into the developer portal and start
using the api's Apogee can also work
with your identity provider which you
have at your end
price they are products like pink
federal site minder octa or what have
you
as long as these products support OAuth
sam'l Open ID Connect based connect
protocols
Appaji can integrate with your identity
providers thereby providing single
sign-on authentication for your app
Abdullah person Appaji can also work
with your partners
Appaji can authenticate your partners
and also the users and like you know app
developers or internet using Open ID
connect and sam'l protocols when it
comes to security and governance and
ensuring that your API development team
is really developing aps and not opening
up vulnerabilities Apogee provides a
cool feature what which is known as flow
hooks flow hooks externalizes the
security responsibilities from an api
proxy developer nearby a security expert
can go in and develop his policies and
also apply the security policies to the
policies that are developed by your api
proxy developers thereby api proxy
developers need not worry about
implementing security and it gets auto
enforced while the api proxies are being
executed at runtime
Appaji provides a confidentiality for
data online and also data at rest you
providing the TLS capabilities for
one-way and two-way TLS for both not
want traffic that is coming in to Apogee
and southbound traffic that is living
from Apogee to your data centers so
these are some of the features which
Apogee provides with respect to security
at a high level now today we will go
over signature based threat protection
module that's where Chris will start his
demo and showcase how Apogee provides
how you can leverage Apogee for
implementing threat protection thanks
this year let's talk a little bit more
details about that problem
API ecosystems can receive malicious
client attacks from both internally as
well as externally
those malicious clients will send
malformed requests to your back-end
systems the API proxy layer can detect
block and report those malformed client
payloads and will inspect the query
parameters the headers as well as the
payloads and block them or report them
before they hit the back-end systems as
you can see from this diagram below the
malicious client is sending both an HTTP
POST as well as a get and trying to
attack the back-end service now open web
application security project is an open
community that focuses on the best
practices of application and API
governance around security protocols
every year they publish a top 10 list of
what enterprises should be looking at
when they're applying these different
types of protections we're going to
focus today on on the number one
injection flaws it's been number one for
probably the last eight years running
input validation is when the client
submits semantical or syntactic
syntactical different types of data
where the structure can be nested
structure like if you have a key value
pair in a JSON payload what happens if
you nest a multiple arrays or multiple
hashes within that key value as well as
you know understanding the value or the
limit of those different query parameter
fields let's say I only request or only
require a limit name and brewery in my
API and then the second injection
follower we're going to take a look at
is sequel code injection this is
commonly noted where a malicious client
will actually send malformed our
contextual aware texts that can actually
pinpoint and hit your database layer
where ie for a relational delete from a
particular schema like delete from
resource this can be applied for sequel
code injection not just relational but
also non-relational as well so with the
API itself in the demo we have a beer
service and that beer service provides a
list of JSON about different be tale
different details about beers Appaji
will be the enforcement point so that
you can have the good
requests go through but the bad requests
we're going actually going to block them
and return bad requests or 400 back to
the client as well as log on them so the
goals of this demo is create an API
proxy that protects against a wash
injection flaws from the client request
payloads as well as query parameters
we're gonna keep it as simple as
possible so that we can walk through and
show you all the details about the
policy itself and third let's report on
the usage that we can identify and some
of our API teams or business folks can
actually learn about from an analytic
perspective now let's take a look at the
API so I'm logging into Apogee and I am
going to go into Apogee edge in the
management interface I'm gonna take a
look at the the API built for this demo
I'll call it the beers on air demo and
I'm gonna go over to the develop tab I'm
gonna pop this open a little bit from
the develop tab you are going to see a
palette of different configuration or
what we call policies within each one of
these policies you can apply different
protections or different enforcement the
policies themselves are broken up into
traffic management security as well as
mediation and you have a whole palette
of easily over 30 different policies
that you can apply to your particular
your particular API proxy for this
particular proxy we're going to look
initially at JSON threat protection and
this has to do with those input input
injections or validations of the client
sending malformed requests payloads so
in this particular example I'm gonna
look for a particular container depth
and make sure there's no arrays within
my structure I'm gonna make sure there's
only three keys in my object entry I'm
gonna make sure the object lengths of
those names is only 50 characters I'm
also gonna make sure the value is not
over 255 characters now the API itself
let me just open this up
of course API doesn't work there we go
my API is returning a list of JSON data
of about that that information now I
already went ahead and created a client
I have a simple single page app once I
go to my single page app I need to
authenticate my user so I'm just going
to do a simple demo user today we're
going to do let's do a jot token once I
have my token I'm gonna actually make a
successful request to that back-end API
now with with the platform itself we
also have the ability to do real time
debugging so if I go open to my proxy
again we have a concept called trace
which allows me to do real time trace
the bugging of that proxy itself so let
me start that that trace section so that
you actually you can see the successful
requests going through initially I'll
hit that refresh again and actually I'll
send a filter mean equals ale you'll see
that it's filtered and when I actually
go into my trace I actually can walk
through each one of those individual
policies that I defined for my threat
protection and make sure that everything
is going through and the client is
receiving those requests so that's an
example of the successful request but
let's take a look and let's try and
implement that JSON protection or that
JSON threat protection so I'll reset
this let's call let's create a new beer
let's just call it a sample beer we'll
have the Google brewery and we'll make
it on air for the style once I make that
success you'll see in my new beers there
I'll go back to my trace you'll see that
the 201 was created so it was a
successful request for actually a post
coming right there now actually I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna send a malformed
there I'm gonna send character string
over 255 characters which I define that
JSON threat protection a lot of the
times clients will have that on client
facing validation but if that's not
there this is going to simulate you know
what happens when the malicious clients
going to send that so let's do a random
characters let's do 256 pipe that too
so I'm gonna change the name now to that
random array of 250 56 characters and
I'll just put a bunch of Brewery and
style for my parameters immediately once
I clicked submit or save theirs I
received that 400 error on my client
you'll see there's details within the
body of the response coming back that
I'm displaying for this demo basically
the JSON threat protection was caught
and there's exceeded string length at
line 1 once I go back once I go back to
my my real-time trace debugger you'll
see that 400 that came in and I can walk
through exactly which policies that were
triggered within my policy window you'll
see that this little icon right here
execution error for JSON threat
protection basically that is where my
API proxy was able to inject and inspect
the payload and realize that that string
character was over that limit so that
was the first example let's take a look
at the second example so second example
we're gonna do parameter validation and
parameter validation I'm gonna use the
ability within our API manager platform
to call out JavaScript and do some
business logic to validate those
particular parameters that are coming in
you'll see that this policy is actually
going to call this parameter underscore
validation AAS I have a set of valid
parameters as well as some of the
pagination that is in my application and
I'm gonna check the length of those
parameters making sure the length is not
greater than what is white listed here
as well as I'm gonna iterate over the
parameters and if any of the parameters
that are sent from the client I'm gonna
fail out and fail gracefully and send
back that error to the client so let's
try this one out my trace is still
running I'm gonna go to my application
let's go to you'll see before that my I
can filter with a successful name
parameter as my as a white listed URL
parameter what happens if I do something
like this users up just like that
another 400 error this time it's just
like before the JSON validation error
this time I'm getting a different
validation on getting parameter
validation and this users will see that
this users is not a valid parameter
likewise when I go back to the the the
trace debugger I can actually trace
through here and when the JavaScript was
executed and actually it's going to
trigger a variable and that variable is
going to set a custom error message this
custom error message message is called
raise parameter validation fault so
within your policies you can use
out-of-the-box ones or you can define
additional custom ones like I did here
and with JavaScript that's example
number two let's take a let's take a
look at the third example let me go back
to my flow last example
it's called sequel code protection and
sequel code is that common reg X or
string that malicious clients try to
inject to manipulate the the data
structures of your database layer and a
lot of applications leverage ORM or
different types of libraries to escape
out some of those racks azure scape out
some of those single quotes sometimes
that's not always the case and sometimes
you need to enforce that within the API
proxy layer so a sequel code product
protection I'm actually going to check
for different reg X's like delete
execute or drop insert or barish
different sequel reg X or sequel code
key parameters that a malicious client
would be would be sending so let's
double check let's see if I my trace is
still running yep I still got some time
going here I'm gonna go back I'm gonna
reset my application you'll see that I
have a successful request coming in this
time let's simulate a malicious client
that's going to try to delete from beers
let's see if it tries to delete from my
beer schema oh just like before I got
another 400 back from a bad request from
my API proxy layer you'll see that that
the details in that false string the
regular expression threat detected was
the sequel code production and just like
before if I walk through my my real-time
debugger within my trace section you'll
see that this time request was received
for client the
the client went through JSON JSON threat
protection was passed parameter
validation was passed this time sequel
code protection was actually triggered
here and the proxy was was hit now
that was how we enforce different
policies from a threat protection
standpoint let's take a look at what's
available for reporting and the third
the third thing of how we want to see
how we report on those different metrics
so within Apogee I have you have the
ability to send custom reports or custom
logging within your proxy layer so with
these individual threat protections I'm
actually going to look for a particular
string or particular validation when the
application is Senate so this error code
I'm actually going to capture this error
code within my policy and then send that
to Apogee rich analytics engine so that
we can have real-time dashboards on the
amount of threats that are coming into
my system that is one way to to capture
the analytics the other way would be to
send to your additional southbound or
northbound systems of your monitoring
systems your syslog your SNMP agents or
any of the event-driven agents that can
capture these different information to
report from a bi perspective so let's
take a look at my policies that I have
added for that within my fault rules I
have a policy called extract fault error
codes and this policy is actually going
to look at the JSON payload or the JSON
structure when a fault
is triggered so I'm actually going to
use JSON path here the JSON path schema
is actually going to look for that error
code and actually capture that as a a
separate a separate variable called
fault error code here once I capture
that error code I'm actually going to
use the statistics collector policy
within Appaji that allows me to send
custom statistic metrics to our
analytics engine so the fault collector
policy you'll see that I'm
actually gonna create a statistic a new
statistics value called full underscore
error code which is going to reference
that variable I just created from that
JSON path then I'm gonna store that into
our analytics engine so if I go back to
my flow within here you'll actually see
that those policies are being executed
on every fault Colet are every fault
that's being triggered
so if I click next within my trace
debugger you'll see that that sequel
code protection was triggered right here
and then if I scroll down you will see
there is where is it I am going to let
me just walk over once more here it is
so here is the error content that was
triggered from that sequel code
protection you'll see that that JSON
structure is right here I'm actually
here is that fault
error code that I'm capturing from that
policy so this this fall error code will
be unique for each one of my policies
that I can report on accordingly once I
hit next you'll see the statistics
collector is actually going to take that
policy and then there's an additional if
I don't want to if a particular error
message occurs I don't want to send a
500 back but so let's go back to our
let's go back to our analytics engine so
within Apogee you have the ability to
see client traffic you have the ability
to see user based traffic proxy based
traffic product based traffic we have a
rich analytics engines that allows you
to dive in into each individual policy
to learn more about how your API program
or your API proxies are performing so if
I go into that custom reporting that I
created I have already created a report
called fault error codes that fault
error codes actually you'll see right
here is reporting on each individual
fault that I enabled within my policies
you'll see that this invalid access
token was when I was not authenticated
or authorized from my client app but
more specifically here is
JSON JSON threat protection here was the
parameter validation and here's the Reg
X protection so I can dive into each one
of these and learn a little bit about
more about each one of those anomalies
so as your API key ecosystem where as
your API platform is evolving you'll see
more and more of this information that
will be useful to block in and
understand what those different types of
threats that are coming in let me reset
that and that actually concludes the
demo I'm gonna go back to my list sweet
that was a nice demo so open up for
question and answers before we do that
yep patient you feel free to sign up on
Apogee comm to get your free trial we
also have hands-on enablement where you
can go through a virtual API jam or
on-site API Jam to learn more about the
different functionality and have your
teams be hands-on into that process and
and on top of that we actually have
product demo webinars like this today
but let's um let's stay tuned for a live
Q&A show and we can be back in less than
a minute
you
looks like we have some great questions
from the audience thank you very much
first question does sequel code
protection policy only applied to
relational databases I'll take this one
this year that's a show yeah so as I
mentioned before the policy itself is
actually regular expression so it can be
applied to all aspects of the client
requests coming in a lot of the
traditional relational database is have
you know that sequel statement that is
more prominent with no sequel coming on
to play a lot of malicious clients are
actually also taking advantage of that
of those different types of some
tactical URL parameters so the same type
of sequel code protection policy that I
applied for delete from schema can also
be applied for particular key spaces or
different structures of no sequel so
that also can apply to non-relational
databases next question should an ORM
database framework library handle all a
sequel injection protection that's
another great one is a lot of many
different software languages have many
different libraries where developers
feel comfortable that that library
abstracts out with object relational
mapping libraries so that when they
build out their applications that they
think they're protected from a security
standpoint there are a lot of flaws in
some of those frameworks and we still
recommend that a a sequel code
protection or a threat protection is
layered on top of the API proxy layer to
protect against some of those are and
frameworks that have flaws actually
we're just read about one from a no
sequel library that actually opened up
based off the or and database framework
a great question
yeah just to add on that so on the I so
think about this as a layered framework
right a PD sits in the first layer it's
like you're bashing and you're
predicting all your security providing
all your security controls at Apogee and
then when the call comes and goes into
your intranet or the back
and it's already protected but so we
need security at each layer just to make
sure that you know we're having enough
security control so it each layer and
there's no hack happening from any of
those layers so that's that the next
question in here's as new OS rules are
published can the API threat protection
policies be updated dynamically Wow
um-hmm so this is a very interesting
question right so the bigger question
behind the question really is if let's
say you develop an API proxy and have
the regular expression which we got from
Oh ass I know injected into the into the
proxy itself it's gonna be a kind of
hard coded for that particular regular
expression now as in when OS is
publishing new a regular expressions how
can we make it more dynamic and this is
like a very interesting question when
approached you can take is to is to
rather than hard coding the regular
expression in the proxy itself you might
want to refer to that regular expression
with a key value right so you might want
to store you a regular expression in our
K key value map storage wherein you can
refer to a regular expression for
example let's say it was sequel
injection specifically for insert attack
right so the key would be sequel
injection underscore insert attack and
then you can refer the value through the
through the from the KVM and that gets
pulled in dynamically now the other part
to this would be how would you hook up
you're always updating your regular
expression to Appaji that you can do
through management API so Appaji
provides management API capabilities for
you to update key value maps or anything
which you can do on any UI there's our
management API for that right so in this
case you would leverage the management
API and tie in our ASPs our updates to
update to trigger an update in your key
value map thereby you need not really
really blow your policies or recreate
your proxies right this becomes a
dynamic that's a lot of value from a
programmatic standpoint and that can be
automated
for your CIC pipeline great great point
nice so this is the question we have
here is how can you monitor militia
spend clients and pattern matching on
rule-based filters Oh interesting yeah
so our Apogee sense provides behavior
based threat protection modules for you
and it's very configurable where matter
of fact we're doing another live webinar
where and we will showcase Apogee sense
and all of its capabilities in detail
but on the shout answer in here is you
would configure your clients on Apogee
sense and you will define rules based on
which Apogee sense will mark a client as
a malicious client or a client which is
a known client but it has its you know
so-and-so usage requirements and that's
the reason why it's sending so much
traffic to you that's a good point
because a lot of the threat protections
that I applied more and more per request
but if you look at those trends over
time how do you how do you take a look
at those those risk patterns and those
threats for tat earns for a larger data
set almost like you know looking at you
know big data and actually using machine
learning to determine what those rules
are for understanding what those
malicious clients and patterns are
totally I think so you know the other
question which we have in here is how do
we how do we have the flow hooks which
are used for our security controls
configured differently based on
different clients so how can we really
do that that's a really good question so
you know the question again to go back
and relate to what we're talking about
in here is the ability which Apogee
provides you to externalize enterprise
security rules and policies so that the
enterprise security engineer can develop
the policies well the security policies
for you but the real question which you
guys are asking in here is how can you
have different rules applied based on
who the client is who the partner is
right so and you know that's really a
valid use case you might want like you
know a higher quota for your premium
clients a little lower quota for your
you know like gold or silver clients
right also to some of your clients might
want to come and authenticate to you
over
and somebody wants to authenticate to
you oversample and a single policy can't
cater to all of these needs and thereby
leading to a multi profile security the
way you will achieve this in Apogee is
by what is known as profile based
security Apogee in Apogee you can define
multiple security profiles and these
security profiles can be configured for
your customers so let's say I'm just
giving this example right let's say Bank
of America is making a call to your API
and then Wells Fargo is making you fall
to your api's and Bank of America wants
to authenticate to you over sam'l and
Wells Fargo wants to authenticate to you
over all the cool thing that Apogee does
it first of all starts your security
process for I didn't with identification
you identify who the caller is and then
you authenticate the caller and then do
you authorize the caller right so once
the authentic identification part is
done at Apogee you would know who the
end-user is in this case it would be
Bank of America right and then you would
write you would direct your flow hook to
a security profile that is applicable
for Bank of America thereby you know
might be Bank of America wants a mole
right now and you go through Samuel
authentication and then authorizations
similarly for this world swagger you
would let them through other channel and
that's actually a very good pattern
right it's called there's a community
article if I remember it right which
calls out which is which is title multi
profile security implementing multi
profile security at your enterprise we
just lost the screen so let's go through
and see the equations I think it's good
for summary for now of what we are oh
yes today sure so apogee is you know the
API management platform that allows you
to enforce security policies that
protect against OS threat protection we
have the flexibility to do that
programmatically and apply some of the
best practices from a standards-based
community and you know I'm like I I
started with an overview of all the
features of abacus
clearly today we focused on the
Tippecanoe prediction but stay tuned for
more such calls and you know we will
more such sessions but we're and we will
be talking about other aspects of
security like authentication our single
sign-on authorization score screen
authorizations finding authorizations in
detail thank you so much and stay tuned
so let's go to the next slide
what's the next there's the next section
which is happening for this so that is
oh yeah so the stage like no oh there's
another session happening that's getting
started with coop flows for kubernetes
ah sounds interesting
oh yeah from the orchestration source
match nice good alright appreciate the
time thank you very much thank you so
much